ANOTHER CHANCE.
>> Kent: F
GOING BACK TO THE OPENING
PERIOD, A THE DUCK FORWARDS,
AHEAD.ORK
IT GOES THROUGH RAKELL TO ZEGRAS
INTO THE VEGAS THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE THAT LEADS TO THE SCORING
CHANCE.
RAKELL WAS TRYING TO THROW THIS
THROUGH THE CREAP WITH IT AS MAN
STEERS IT ASIDE.
DUCKS ONUST INSIDE
THE OFFENSIVE BLUE LINE.
HE TRIED TO GET TO AT THIS  RETE
GROUND RUNNING.
NO.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T THINK ZEGRAS TOUCHES ITT
FLYING A PLAYER OUTSTOLARZ.
A
24 SHOTS FOR THE DUCKS.WIN,
MILANO DROPS IT BACK AND IT'S
ZEGRAS THAT SETS NOW
HARD-AROUND TO MILANO WHO'S
ALONE ON
ZACH WHITECLOUD ALL THE WAY DOWN
ATAYS GOING FAST.
HE HAS ITOSITE
END HERE ON ZEGRAS.
.
DRYSDALE BACK TO PICK IT UP AND
HE'LL GALLOP TO CENTER WITH IT.
TURNOVER THAT CAN'T HAPPEN.
ZEGRAS IS TRYING TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN
MILANO OVER TO ASSIST.
DRYSDALE.
GIVES IT
MILANO JUST FLIES UP THE LEFT
WING AND DRYSDALE OFF THE RIGHT
POINT IS JUST
ALL TIME IN 21 MEE
LONG SHOT, JUST ABSORBED TO PRO
PUCK.
STONE POPS IT BACK, CARRICKOOTE.
YOU KIND OF KNOW WHEN HE'S ON
THE ICE ON THIS POWER PLAY, WHEN
THE PUCK'S ON THE STICK NOT LEF.
5-4 DUCKS.
AHEAD FOR MARCHESSAULT, STEAM S.
ANTHONY STOLARZ
POINTER AGAINST DIVISIONAL  IT
LEHNHN